- You do have to
reinvent yourself.
I remember a therapist
telling me that,
she's like everyone
in show business
you have to
- She specifically said
you need to reinvent yourself,
you know I've seen your act.
- Dye your hair blonde.
- She's here like you've
never said a funny thing
in your life, you're never funny
and I'm like that's
not what I'm here for.
But I remember her saying that
- Somebody sent
me to a therapist
about eight years ago
and I'm not gonna say
who sent me but he said you
should go see this therapist
to deal with like, you
know I was getting backlash
and haters and
all the stuff that
that I wasn't prepared
for was going on,
he goes you should
go to this therapist
he works with all
comedians he gets us.
- Oh dear.
- He speaks our language.
He knows the jargon.
- Oh he knows what
Montreal means.
(laughs)
That's what they always
say about that therapist,
I know who you're talking about.
- I get into this
therapy session
literally the first
thing this guy says to me
sitting straight across me,
put his hand on his legs
he goes Dane Cook, your
name comes up a lot in here.
- [Everyone] Oh my god!
- [Nikki] Of course it
does, of course it does.
- I was just broken
in half at that point.
(laughs)
(rock music)
- And we're back at You
Up with Nikki Glaser
in studio we've
got Andrew Collin,
Shulli Egar, and now
Dane, again, Cook.
(applause)
Dane Cook is here.
- I led my own applause praise.
- Yeah you started it out.
Dane Cook is here
kicking off a huge tour.
You haven't been on
tour, a big, a tour
- Since 1984.
(laughs)
- 2013 I mean that's a while.
- I know it was,
you know how it is,
it's like when you're
cultivating new material
sometimes you're on a groove
and it comes together in a year,
a year and a half you're
like I'm good to go,
and then there's other
times in your life where
I've been doing it 29 years,
you're still going through
like an evolution of
really perspectives,
and being introspective,
that all need to lend
itself to our material.
So I took a little more
time with it this time
because I felt like I
wanted to get it perfect.
- I'm excited because you were,
that's true, you were
so famous and so huge,
so quickly, then you came out
with special special special
because the demand
was, you needed to
- Yes.
- And you could, I
mean, you did it.
But I'm interested to see
what what's happened now
with this five years gap, where,
what kind of material, what's
been the shift for you?
- Yeah you know,
did you see the,
you saw the Channeling
documentary?
- Yes.
- The thing about that that
kind of congealed everything
for me is I grew
up loving Carling
and this an unbelievable moment.
Carling was doing the
hippy dippy weather man,
he had the cardboard
cutout of himself
that he brought out on I
guess the tonight show,
and in this prolific
moment he walked out,
he used, you know
it was lucrative,
the hippy dippy weather
man was doing well for him
and everybody knew him as that,
so he brought the cardboard
cutout out and he said
he was like, lot of
people know this guy
he was hilarious,
we all loved him,
but this guy, and he dropped
his own picture out of frame,
he goes is gone.
I'm George Carlin,
alright let's start.
- [Nikki] Wow.
- And it was this dead silence
cause everybody was like what
what is this gonna be
- He shot it down.
And that was even really
before I got into stand
up comedy full time
and I thought oh wait, you
can evolve in this business,
you don't have to
stay as one thing
or, people will pigeon
hole you and say
you're the guy that
rips his shirt off
and his pants saying you
pour water on yourself
and that's what you do forever.
But I already looked at this now
I can grow up with a
generation of comedy fans.
- I love that, you always kill
it on these late night shows,
you're one of my favorite
late night guest,
and you have been since, I
remember when you went on chemo
right after the
Tom Cruise incident
where he jumped on the couch
- Jumped on the couch.
- On Oprah.
- Did I chase somebody
into a bathroom?
- Dude, you were so funny!
And I pulled it up
- yeah he sent it to me
it was unbelievable.
- A month ago.
- Who did I chase
into a restroom?
- You, it was some
actress that you had
stationed in, because (laughs)
because if you don't remember
when tom Cruise was on
Oprah he went to go fetch
Katie Holmes backstage
and made like a huge thing
about it, but she had
like a thing on her lips,
so she didn't
wanna be on camera,
and he's like come on Katie.
So you, you come out on chemo
just so committed to look
I'm in love (yells) I'm in love,
and just doing the
best impression
- I had a tattoo but
it was a magazine
that I taped in my back.
- It was so funny, you
have to watch Dane Cooke,
Jimmy Kimel, Tom cruise,
just search those words,
it is such, you're
so committed to that
and it wasn't like
something you would,
it wasn't the Dane
Cook that we knew
at that point which was, I mean
you're not an impressionist
like that wasn't what
I expected out of you.
But it was so killer.
- Yeah Kimal has always
been like that place
that they let you
go and try things
that are out of your lane
or whatever it is the
perspective which is great.
- But that could
have gone so badly.
- Oh yeah.
- It was so, that was a whole
- I'm sure there's another
clip you can look up online
(laughs)
we'll dig those up so you
can see some of the ones
where it didn't go so great.
- But I love the fact that,
in your mind as a comic
and as a performer you're like,
this has to go somewhere,
and I'm just gonna walk
out there and just talk
like, I wanna do some,
I wanna bring
something to the table.
- My comedy from the beginning,
I grew up I was a real
introvert, you know,
I had anxiety and panic
attacks, I was like,
I had no social
skills whatsoever.
So anytime I got on
stage, and the fact
that I even ever
stood on a stage
when I couldn't be in
front of, you know,
even at the bus stop
waiting to go to school
I was panicking, it
was like torture.
So it's like every
single opportunity
I have to get up
there, I wanna commit.
Everything I had
because I loved it.
I hated being off stage,
I was more scared in life
than I was of how
I felt on stage.
And I think that's
permitted my entire career
of like, I gotta take
full advantage of this
while I can be out
here and feeling this,
the bravado that comes
with standing on stage.
- So you don't
take it for granted
every time you go
on stage, you really
- Never.
- Cause I heard
you talk about that
and I'm always like I wish I
felt the way about the stage
that Dane Cook feels
because I've heard you talk
about this feeling of I
just want to get up there
and you cherish every movement
- Yeah yeah it's
always been glamorous.
Ever since I saw
when I was a kid
watching Johnny Carson
growing up, or Carling,
or Prior, it was like I watched
all these amazing comedians
and to me it always felt
like wow that's like,
that's a occupation where
you're always needed
- Yeah.
- To some extend you know?
And I think I wanted to
feel that growing up,
I wanted to feel like
needed, I had a place.
So once I locked
into it I was like
this is what I'm good at,
I suck at pretty much
everything else in the world so
I just give it all I got.
- Well I wanna go back
to something you said
about just having
extreme anxiety
I was the same way growing up I,
giving class presentations
I would just,
I would have panic attacks,
I wouldn't be able to sleep
for three days before
because I was so nervous.
Everything in my childhood
you would have looked
at me as a child you'd be like
that girl will never
be a stand up comedian.
And you were having panic
attacks at the bus stop,
how does one overcome that?
If you're listening, someone's
listening now being like
I wanna do stand
up comedy but it's,
I'm too scared, what do you find
that was, made you
be able to do it?
- I think that I
was funny at home,
I would get home and I
felt like that was just,
I was safe you know,
so I could do skits
or I would, you know,
prank phone calls
with my little radio
shack plug in you know,
I would make my own
Jerkey boy type calls,
and I got a rush out
of getting laughs
if I would play for a
couple of my friends
or my family, and so I think,
I remember watching Martin
Short on Saturday Night Live
when I was like
seven or eight grade,
and he was doing Ed Grimly,
he was doing Jacky Roberts
Junior 100 000 dollars
jackpot won, and he
just, he was so happy.
He was so into it.
And I wanted that really
desperately in my life.
And so I thought I'm gonna
try an open mic night,
and how that happened was kind
of a quick story interesting
I was in Cambridge Massachusetts
at Catch Rising Star,
I was watching David Cross
was doing his own cross comedy
within open mic night,
so he do sketches
then he bring part
luck performers up.
You'd sign up and then
you'd show up the next week,
and if he called your name
you got pulled up on stage.
Well I was just going to
watch cause I was terrified
at actually going up
there, and the third week,
the host went up and said
okay, next on the list
and they would randomly call
you where's Ernest Glen?
And there's like three
seconds of nothing,
then I knew this
guy wasn't there,
they were gonna move
on to the next name,
I put my hand up, he
goes you're Ernest Glen
I say yeah and he goes alright
all the way from the
fifth row Ernest Glen.
And that was my first set ever.
And once I did it it felt
the way I did up there
I said this is, I gotta
- I'm Ernest now.
- I gotta do it again.
- I'm Ernest Glenn
- Identity theft I love it.
Old school.
- What happened the next
week when you were Dane Cook?
- I never found this
Ernest Glenn guy either.
There was never an Ernest
Glenn in Boston comedy
and I would Facebook try to
find him from time to time
I wanted to thank him.
- It'd be great if you
crushed and you couldn't go
by your regular name, and then
that guy just said somewhere
Ernest Glenn HPS
fest what the fuck?
- Ernest Glenn is Amy's
Dane Cook somewhere.
(laughs)
- I mean, no one was more
famous than you in 2008,
is that where we're
talking that's right?
- I think everything
really started yeah,
five, six, seven, eight,
everything was kind of a blur.
Even though I remember
all these high water marks
- I mean, what does
it look like to you
when you think back
on it like what are,
that must have been, I
mean there's, no one has
that experience, I can
only name a couple people
who've had that skyrocketing.
- There's a lot of columns in,
okay so first of all look
at it mostly as, you know,
this pipe dream came true,
so I was grateful beyond
because I had a career and
it looked like I'd be able
to take it as far as I
wanted, willing to work,
I could take it as
far as I wanted to go.
So you had all these high
watermark moments of like
I'm hosting SNL or I'm playing
Madison Square Garden or I'm
- [Nikki] Rolling
Stones magazine cover.
- I'm affiliating myself
with, I know Rolling Stones,
I mean they smashed me
like a year later but
that was the next
wave of what happens
- Of course.
- And I accepted that the
same way I accepted the praise
cause I knew it was all just
a fucking spanking ultimately
- The chair was covered right?
- Yeah yeah.
- Did you know, you knew
the backlash was coming?
- I think I helped
(laughs) I was like
I'm gonna tear down too,
I'm ready to devolve
and then evolve again.
- Because you're right, you
cannot sustain the level of fame
and adoration and just
wild energy around you
at that time, that's
not sustainable
so you knew it was
gonna be taken away?
- I did and the thing that was,
not taken away I just
knew that it would crust
you know what I mean?
- I guess I look at
it I'm always like
if I get as famous
as I wanna be,
it will be taken away,
that's how I look at it.
- That's, we're in it for
the long haul we're gonna
you know, are you Jerry
Louis, at 90 years old
I'd see him perform,
at 90 years old
I went backstage one
time, he would do a Q&A
at the very end of a show,
usually lasted about 35 minutes,
people would line up, ask
questions, it was hilarious
cause he was salty and
he was honest and so
- He didn't give a shit.
- He didn't give a shit right?
But it was awesome, and
so he did not the 35
he did like 15, and I walked
backstage and he was pissed,
and nobody was near him
and his daughter was like
oh Jerry wants to
see you I was like
I don't even wanna go
near him he looks upset
she was like no he wants
to talk to a comedian
he needs to talk to you,
so I walked up there
and he goes, I
remember 90, he goes
they fucking let me early.
(laughs)
I had another 15 of Q&A.
At 90 I said, this never ends.
- [Nikki] Never.
- We are never
gonna be satisfied.
- [Nikki] You're right.
- It's just ever
you know, changing,
and fans are gonna come and go,
be like uh you're not as
funny as your last thing
and then they come around it's
like being an Aerosmith fan,
I didn't like that
album but now I'm back
but now what are you
doing but now I'm back.
I looked at a career
as like people visit
and they're gonna come
and they're gonna go.
- But even when you were
at the pinnacle of success
what does it feel
like you're like
I got everything I could
have ever dreamed of,
I mean that is wild.
- Yeah the big up
shock was the level of
what I could share with
fans and my family you know?
I was very close to my mom
and my dad and it was like
everything that I
accomplished and got to show,
especially my mom was
like a mind blowing thing
cause she knew who
I really was from 14
and feeling so broken you know?
Loathing myself at
a very young age,
now she's watching me on camera
where I hated who I was
and now she's seeing me
you know, filming in front
of thousands of people.
The thing that was
the hardest was
what fame gets you,
superstardom and fame,
what it really does
when you get there is
it invites you and
it exposes you to
okay ready welcome now here's
everyone that hates you.
And your lane's here, and
you gotta remember that,
and most people drift
off for years to come
and then you try to
get back to your lane.
The thing that is the most
gratifying is the more you have
the more you can do
for other people.
That's the cool thing.
Whether it's, you know,
going to children hospitals
or, you have so much
more clout to be able
to shine lights on things
that you want people
to know or performers
or products,
so that's the part that
was probably the trickiest
to have to re jigger you
know, what I'm gonna do.
- Yeah, what was the
biggest surprise,
I'm just fascinated by fame,
and I think it's all some,
we love doing comedy but
there is a part of us
that just wants to
be loved by everyone,
and we want fame,
whatever that is,
what was some things that
you didn't maybe foresee
when you would
become that famous?
That became, was
going out in public,
did you become more
paranoid, wanna stay in more,
those kinds of things?
- I was always like home
buddy or where you know,
I built my fanbase
up through MySpace
and early social networking
because I wasn't a go out
kind of person you know,
I'm 46 I'm, you know,
this makes me lame
I never had a drink
or drug in my whole life,
I didn't do that stuff.
- You're a cop, I'm out of here.
- I'm a cop.
(laughs)
I just, I loved the
minutia of what it meant
to have that
correspondence with fans,
that really was kind
of a kick for me.
And also you gotta remember,
I could be comfortable at home
talking to everybody, it
took away that anxiety
that I felt of off stage
how I deal with people,
so that, sitting in my
underwear with fruit loops
and like writing
thousands of people
that was like my
sweet spot I was like,
this is great, yeah.
- You touched on some of that,
I don't think enough
people give you credit for
and that is literally
creating a world
where comedians can
promote themselves
via social media, the
internet, what you did
on MySpace, you know, we talked
about being in the pinnacle
of fame for you, but
the way you got there,
the hassle, the fucking,
I respect hassling people
so much man
- Me too.
- And so many comics,
you've helped so many comics
by putting that
process together,
that template of going
online and hammering,
like how does MySpace not
sent you a fucking cheque?
(laughs)
- I gotta say you're
nailing it because I
- They really did,
but just not directly.
- Fuck yeah man.
(laughs)
- I think about Dane
Cook every single weekend
because I, when I do shows,
and I do meet and
greets afterwards,
I sometimes don't want to, I'm
tired, I don't feel like it,
I have another show to do,
people are gonna get grabby,
it's gonna upset me,
but I do it because I go
that's how Dane, I know that's
how Dane built his audience,
they have a connection with
them, those people will,
if they meet me and
have a good moment,
they will be my fans for life.
- It's truly true.
- And I remember you either
reading that you said that
or, I just know that about you,
that you would take
the time after shows,
spend hours meeting fans.
- Longer than the shows.
- I mean how, do
you still do that?
I mean you, that can't be
sustainable at your level now.
- Yeah I mean, I still
do meet and greets,
you know with a tour
like this it's hard
cause we're moving to the
next thing like that night.
But if people are
waiting outside
or at the bus it's like,
I'm gonna be there you know,
I wanna make sure I
can still, you know,
hang with whoever
wants to meet me,
it's still
- It's really inspiring.
- It's really gratifying,
you know what I mean?
It's like people want to,
you know, 29 years later,
it's like people are as
excited to come to a show.
And the thing that was
cool about when I hear it,
when people say back to me
like this is what you did,
that was also at a
time where it just,
the old era of comedy
at that point was
you didn't do that stuff.
- You posted flyers
on windshields, parks
- I was, I was barking, I
was like doing everything,
but that was like not
in vogue at the time,
and I got a lot of crap for it,
but it just felt like, I felt
like I was doing something
in the never been
done before business.
- Right.
- So I wasn't following
anybody else's lead in that.
- You were leading the way.
- So I was like if
I fuck up it's okay
because nobody knows what's
right and wrong with this.
- You're that dude, you're
the dude with a machete
just chopping shit
going follow me guys.
- And I literally
held the machete
how do you know all this?
- I know.
(laughs)
- I'm just sitting at
my dull computer
- While you're on MySpace.
(laughs)
Yeah because it is, comedians
they wanna roll their eyes
at any kind of self promotion,
you're just supposed
to hate yourself,
and you're just
supposed to, that's
what a comic is supposed
to be just very,
just stick to the course,
do your set, leave,
if you win against anything
- it's not the world anymore.
- It wasn't cool
to promote yourself
and you didn't care and
listen you, now we all do it.
- I didn't care
because it was like
oh wow, I get to
have a great life,
I get to have a couple
cool things if I need it,
get to take care of my family,
bought my mom a house
when I was 29 years old
(laughs)
you know, it's like, a
welfare kid from Massachusets
and I get to buy my mom a house.
- [Nikki] It's so cool.
- Everything that
people wanna say like,
but wasn't it, you know,
wasn't it so difficult
to have A, B and C yeah, there
were definitely hardships,
tough times, but every
day I could wake up and go
there's a stage somewhere
I can get on tonight,
and I know I can get
laughs, and at the end
of like whatever
this long career is,
I hope I'm 90 complaining
backstage like my mentor.
But I look at it and
go, to be able to,
night after night, get on
stage and try to figure out
something that connects
with the crowd,
that is the challenge
that never gets boring
or lessen you know.
- That's, yeah, because there's,
you always have to write,
you always have to
come up with new stuff,
it never gets boring
you're so right.
Tickets for his tour Tell it
like it is are on sale now.
Tell it like it is
what are we gonna,
what are you talking
about on this tour,
what's the title come from?
- A lot of the title
is, I wanted to get
to a point in my stand up
where I could use every
tool in the arsenal
in terms of like, I
still love physicality
but I'm 46 I'm not
gonna drop kick
and do, you know,
on the mic stand
or whatever I was doing before,
but I still have
that same, you know,
enthusiasm, that's just,
that's organic you know?
It's like when you see
Chris Rock practicing
he's lowkey, and then
you see him on a show
and it just, you know, you know,
you get in show mode
and you get up there
and it all kind of you know,
comes into the character.
But I didn't ever
want the character
to be somebody whom when I
saw you on the meet and greet
felt like it was so different
or a put on from the show,
I want to be able to pretty
much keep the demeanor
and walk up and meet you
and know I can say to you
I have two minutes, dude come on
let's fucking take the
picture and get out of here.
And it's okay, cause
you know who I am,
you know what I'm about,
with the routine now
and why I brought
Gary Shamley up was
I just love the idea that
you could get introspective.
And I didn't, I had a lot of
observation for many years,
but I wanted the introspection
so desperately, so
- It's scary to do that.
- It's scary.
- You dig up a lot of shit.
- You're digging up
stuff but, with insight,
some of these things
that happened to me
that have been in
the moment like so,
just, you know, almost cap
sizing moments of my life,
are hilarious, now
that I'm sharing them
and telling the stories.
But why it took a
little longer to key was
I didn't want to be modeling.
I didn't wanna be like, hey
this is more one man show
because it's introspect,
no no no, I want LPM,
laughs permitted, the same thing
that you saw on Vicious
Circle or Retaliation,
but with things that are
even more deeply personal.
So now that I've got that,
we're doing every damn city
in the entire country.
- [Nikki] I'm so excited how
long are you on tour for?
A while.
- At least until September
and then we're already looking
at like the future of it all and
- Yes I'm so excited
- Oh thank you.
- To see your new act,
I've always been a fan
and I haven't seen
you for so long
I'm excited cause you did
go through some shit man.
- Yeah.
- I mean, and you have gotten
into some serious stuff
in your past stand
up, did you feel
like you were modeling
then, with that stuff?
Are you approaching
it different, or?
- Yeah I think with what
you're speaking of was like,
when I did Isolated
Incidents, that came after
you know my mom and dad
had passed away, cancer,
same year, nine months,
both of my best friends
just like gone, and then
I went through the stuff
with my brother and this
whole financial thing,
and then I went through
the stuff with CK,
and it was like within
a three year period,
all these, you know pressurized,
highly pressurized moments
were happening to me.
So that was reflected
in Isolated Incidents
and I called it that
because I felt like
how I felt in that
time in my life
was going to be an
isolated incident,
I knew I'd get past
it and get to like
whatever I felt before, a
new normal kind of thing,
to quote Oprah, a new normal.
And so I don't look
at it as modeling
but I just look at
that particular,
I'm very fond of that show,
Mardy Colner directed it,
he directed Vicious
Circle as well
- It's intimate, it
was just a departure
from what we had seen from you.
- The challenge that
year, I always have
kind of a new year
challenge for myself,
and wanted to had
something to you know,
extend the abilities
or opportunities
to tell different
kinds of stories was,
the whole year I
planted my feet,
I kept the mic in the mic
stand and never moved.
For one year,
January fucking first
to the end of the year,
I did not move on stage.
And so when I did that show
- Wow.
- It was to prepare me from
being all the animation
to can I tell a whole
show with just my eyes.
- [Nikki] Wow.
- That's crazy.
There's so many comics I know
that are just the opposite,
they're like I'm on
stage, I'm just standing
in one spot, I
should move around to
- Well you know but, that
makes sense that you did that
because, you know, people
were so jealous of you,
and so angry at your success,
that you became someone
that people would,
the pacing the stage,
the things that we all
fucking loved about you
and made you so funny,
that was then being mocked.
- Yeah Family Guy and
all that kind of stuff
- Of course, everywhere, I mean
you were so fucking huge dude.
And people wanted
to make fun of it
even though it was
what got you there
and what we all loved.
So it makes sense that you
were like, you know what?
I can still do this
without all that shit,
and I'll prove it to you.
And that's really cool that you,
what was your
challenge this year?
I mean every year
you have a new thing?
- Not so much this
year but about two,
after I did Troublemaker,
Troublemaker was
the last special on show
time that I directed,
my first time directing
- What was that like?
- Amazing, because for
the first time ever
you know as a
comedian we finish it
and then sometimes other
people are impending
on the process and, maybe
an edit is weird or,
there's always a
little something inky.
I wanted to have something
that from start to end
I could create and say you know,
this is entirely how I saw
it and wanted it to be,
the exact, the whole show.
And so from that I
really, I loved that,
I loved that feeling of freedom,
and I liked that I could, I
can say no to a bunch of stuff,
because of the opportunities
comedy has given me,
and I can say yes to
like one particular thing
that I'm trying to accomplish.
So the last three years have
really been about this material
it just took a little bit longer
because like I said I wanted to,
I wanted to dig into the
real nitty gritty of it all.
- I'm so excited because
when you came on the scene
with your comedy
central presence
which was just
- O one, yeah 2001.
- Dude, I mean, that's,
wasn't that the first thing
that people just go
what the, like this guy?
- Yeah, oh and me too
I was like oh my god
what the fuck, this is working.
- That was crazy.
- Yeah before that it was
a lot of years of you know.
- I mean, but that was
- A different what the fuck.
- That was what your debut,
and you had worked so,
you'd been working so many years
to have that kind of
splash and now I'm excited
to see all the work
that you've again
kind of put into this, to
make a new kind of splash.
Like it's exciting, and
I'm just such a fan,
and I really am
grateful as a comedian
for what you've done for us.
- Oh thank you, that means
a lot to me thank you.
- It's true dude, like I
remember getting into stand up
when I first started
thinking about doing it,
listening to Harmful
Sword and I still remember
the stoplight I was
at in Lawrence Kansas
when I was laughing
out loud so hard
in a way that I had never
laughed out loud that hard.
And I was like there's something
so special about this guy,
I was a huge fan I came
to see you in Vegas
when you did the Insomniac tour.
- Yeah yeah.
- I flew with my friends
there to go see you
- Oh that was a great show.
- Cause I was such a fan.
I got picked to be seat filler,
cause I had a regular seat
but we were like two hot girls
so they asked us to
sit in the second row,
then I got to go to the
VIP party afterwards
because we were seat
fillers, and they didn't know
I was a comedian, I just
started a couple months ago,
I told my friends I go,
you do not tell anyone
I'm doing stand up,
that is humiliating,
these guys are pros,
don't mention it.
And she drunkenly went
up to you and was like
my friend just started
comedy and I go no,
and you were so, so cool, you
didn't need to do this at all
and it was the
last thing I wanted
was to bother you after
the show in this taping
but you go come here,
I have some advice.
You took me in the corner
and you just hounded on me
and you go, here's the
deal, don't go to New York
or LA, it's too soon
for you, go to Boston,
go to Chicago, go to
Denver, go somewhere else,
work out, you just gave me
this TED talk that was like
(laughs)
that just to the point
- This is so me
- Exactly what I needed
to hear
- This is what happens.
- There was no other
bullshit involved,
you were so nice,
and it was just,
I just like stood
there, took it all in,
and like did that,
I followed it,
and it was great advice,
the same kind of advice
I give to people, but the
fact that you took the time
to do that in that night
really meant something to me,
and it speaks to your
character and I appreciate it.
- Oh wow.
- You didn't walk away going
wow this guy is not
so animated off stage.
- I feel like why
didn't he hit on me?
- I was a little
offended I gotta say
but you were all
I think everyone drank
and stayed up too late
and you were, you
were professional,
you did what you needed
to do and I was like
oh he's just going home,
like you're an introvert.
- That was it, yeah.
I mean honestly,
even to this day,
you know when I do
the meet and greet,
I love meeting people but
that's still the hardest part
you know it's just
- Sitting through the jokes.
(laughs)
- [Nikki] Yeah.
- He's so racist.
- You are so racist.
- Always.
- Dane Cook is on tour now,
you gotta go see him guys,
the tour is called
Tell it like it is,
you can find all the tour
dates on danecook.com,
he's gonna be on
tour till September
going everywhere,
so wherever you are,
he's going to be there
somewhere close by,
go see him, danecook.com,
Dane Cook thank you so much
- You're the best
thank you so much.
- Thank you, thank you
- Appreciate it.
(rock music)